met latrell sprewell in a bar in
milwaukee and he was like my favorite
player as a kid yeah you know nick's
legend and yeah he was so i met him in a
bar and i was like
i was i was playing like some [ __ ]
club in milwaukee
and i was by the way i'm in a knicks
sweatshirt like i'm a big knicks fan
yeah and i'm in the bar with uh
you know the host from the show she's
like you know just so you know spreewell
hangs at this bar all the time and i'm
like yeah okay spree [ __ ] walks in
whoa and he's in like sweatpants and all
that stuff and they're like you know get
him a drink he drinks honey jack i'm
like of course he does like an idiot i
walk over to him
a huge fan man he's like okay
and i'm like uh
can i get you a drink already got one
and i'm like i'm like i'm like fishing
my head for [ __ ] i can say and i said uh
i'm playing the comedy club like i don't
know what to say i panicked and i said
if you want to come and he goes yeah
don't count on it oh my god
i'm getting destroyed by spearo's like
alright nice to meet you